guten tag liebe kolleginnen liebe
kollegen herzlich willkommen zur
regierungspressekonferenz an diesem
mittwoch immer noch wie auf absehbare
zeit im sonderbus aufgelockerte sitz
ordnung hier einige kolleginnen
sprecherinnen und sprecher im saal
verteilt
wir arbeiten auch für diese
pressekonferenz wieder so dass die
mitglieder der bundespressekonferenz und
des vereins der auslandspresse sich von
außen gewesen diesen diese
pressekonferenz von außen über einen
speziellen livestream verfolgen können
und wahrscheinlich die möglichkeit haben
fragen zu stellen das ipad dass wir
dafür brauchen wir gerade noch mal
gestartet alle wissen wir üben da noch
wir müssen gucken ob das jetzt klappt
wir versuchen das zu machen ich sage
jetzt schon wenn wir die möglichkeit
haben fragen von außen rein zu nehmen
dann kann ich nicht jede frage einzelnen
vorzuleben und nicht einzeln vorlesen
weil viele fragen sich thematisch
überschneiden ich werde dann versuchen
das zu bündeln und bittet diejenigen die
von außen fragen stellen dafür
verständnis damit zu haben jetzt
wirklich gerade das signal haben wir das
ding da genau also da laufen die waren
aber das ist nicht komplett
übersichtlich ich bitte da schon jetzt
um verständnis wenn das nicht immer
optimal gelingt aber wir versuchen das
zu machen
sodann begrüßen wir natürlich unsere
gäste
die stellvertretende
regierungssprecherin syke thema und die
sprecherinnen und sprecher der
ministerien und wie immer am mittwoch
beginnt die stellvertretende
regierungssprecherin mit dem bericht aus
dem bundeskabinett bitte jetzt genau ist
in guten tag
die bundesregierung hat heute die
eckwerte für den regierungsentwurf des
bundeshaushaltes 20 21 sowie für den
finanzplan bis zum jahr 2024 beschlossen
der eckwertebeschluss ist die grundlage
für das weitere regierungsinterne
haushalts aus aufstellungsverfahren das
bundesministerium der finanzen hat sie
bereits glaube ich über einzelheiten
informiert und auch deutlich gemacht
dass wir uns in einer
außergewöhnlichen und volatilen lage
befinden des corona virus ist eine
ernsthafte herausforderung forderungen
auch für unsere gesamte gesellschaft und
noch kann niemand da ja genau die
tragweite seriös beziffern die eine
solche pandemie auf die konjunkturelle
entwicklung in deutschland haben wird
die bundesregierung wird den
wirtschaftlichen auswirkungen mit aller
kraft entgegentreten und hat dazu
bereits erste notwendige maßnahmen
ergriffen
ziel muss es sein neben der vorrangigen
stärkung unseres gesundheitssystems
unternehmen zu schützen und
arbeitsplätze zu sichern
soweit hier für weitere maßnahmen
erforderlich sind werden sie dann im
rahmen der weiteren aufstellung des
haushalts 20 21 berücksichtigt werden
mit den eckwerten setzt die
bundesregierung die vom
koalitionsausschuss am 8 märz
beschlossene verstärkung der
investitionen des bundes um jeweils 3,1
milliarden euro auf 42,9 milliarden euro
pro jahr um die zusätzlichen mittel sind
vor allen dingen für infrastrukturen
digitalisierungen vorgesehen
insgesamt stehen damit von 2020 bis 2024
investitionsmittel von rund 215
milliarden euro zur verfügung um die
zukunfts und innovationsfähigkeit der
wirtschaft zu stärken und deutschland
weiter zu modellen
und dann hat das kabinett heute den
bericht der bundesregierung zur lage und
zum deutschen engagement in mali sahel
beschlossen
der bericht soll der bundestag über die
lage in der region und das deutsche
engagement vor ort informieren
die sicherheitslage in mali und der
region hat sich in den letzten jahren
zusehends verschlechtert die
bundesregierung beabsichtigt daher auf
bitten der regierung der sache staaten
ihr schon bislang breit aufgestelltes
engagement in abstimmung mit ihren
internationalen partnern abermals zu
verstärken
maßnahmen zur bekämpfung der ursachen
von gewalt und terrorismus können nur
durchgeführt werden wenn ein ausreichend
sicheres umfeld gegeben ist dass es
derzeit in weiten teilen der region
nicht der fall deshalb müssen die
internationalen anstrengungen zur
verbesserung der sicherheitslage
ausgeweitet werden
deutschland verfolgt in der region am
letzten ansatz deswegen unterstützt die
bundesregierung insbesondere marie aber
auch die anderen saal staaten bei den
eigenen anstrengungen auf dem weg hin zu
stabilen geeinten pluralistischen
demokratischen staaten
und so wird die bundesregierung im
rahmen des vernetzten ansatzes unter
anderem auch ihr schon bislang breit
aufgestelltes engagement in abstimmung
mit den internationalen partnern
abermals verstärken und zeitnah anträge
zur fortsetzung der beteiligung
bewaffneter deutscher streitkräfte in
der vn stabilisierungsmission minustah
und der eu-geführten ausbildungs und
beratungsnetz tm mali vorgeben vorliegen
und damit bin ich durch bevor er zu den
fragen kommt nochmal organisatorisch
hinweis es laufen jetzt schon sehr sehr
viele fragen von außen ein noch mal der
hinweis ich werde versuchen das zu
bündeln so weit mir das hier gelingt das
auch für mich übersichtlich zu halten
und zweitens schlage ich vor dass wir
die themen jetzt hier nicht alle unter
der überschrift krone erstellen
sondern so ein bisschen bündeln und zwar
auch mit blick darauf dass wir dann ihr
wechsel auf dem podium haben sodass ich
vorschlage der bündeln erst mal fragen
die sich um das thema kanzleramt
kanzlerin eu-banken dann auch dazu
wirtschaft finanzen haushalt was den
kabinettsbeschluss angeht da müssen wir
nicht wechseln
dann könnte man als eigenen themenblock
danach im wechsel weil dann
wahrscheinlich das
bundesverteidigungsministerium gefragt
oder bundeswehreinsätze und auch die
bundeswehr im rahmen corona sprechen und
ich würde dann als eigenen blog auch
aufrufen
das was sich primär an innenministerium
richtet auch das thema grenzschutz auch
dazu kommen von außen schon viele fragen
würde ich dann den eigenen themenblock
nehmen in dem sinne fangen wir an thema
bundeskanzlerin eu vielleicht mal herr
blank
und lagen sich in den armen
das ist keine kritik an deutschland zu
langsam um ihr vorhaben wird also
zunächst ja das bundeskabinett hat heute
im internationalen konferenzsaal tag
ich habe es nicht nochmal extra
recherchiert aber ich gehe davon aus
dass das das erste mal der fall war und
ich habe mich ja hier auch schon
ausführlich in den vergangenen
regierungs pressekonferenz geäußert die
bundesregierung passt ihre passt die
maßnahmen der lage folgend und dem rat
der experten folgen kontinuierlich an
wir haben in dieser woche zahlreiche
maßnahmen beschlossen
ich möchte jetzt nicht auf einzelne
äußerungen befreundeter partner eingehen
möchte nur darauf hinweisen dass ist ja
gestern eine video-konferenz des
europäischen rates auch zu diesem thema
gegeben hat und deutschland natürlich
großes interesse an
der solidarität innerhalb europas hat
und zu diesem zweck gibt es ja auch
solche zusammenkünfte
man hat dort auch gestern gemeinsam das
einreiseverbot nach europa aus ländern
die weder der europäischen union noch
der efta angehören beschlossen
wichtig war ebenfalls der den freien
güterverkehr zu sichern
insofern würde ich sagen im geiste
dieser beschlüsse ist zu sehen die
zusammenarbeit in europa bleibt von
großer bedeutung
ich kann ihnen zu den dialogen einzelnen
dialogen in der schalter nicht sein
gehen gleich noch eine bitte zur
geschäftsordnung nachfragen kurz zu
halten war wirklich die frage durch die
möglichkeit von außen zu fragen die
frageliste explodiert gerade andreas
rinke dann theorie
zahlen die rückhol aktionen die wir
starten richtet sich zunächst an
deutsche reisende aber wir gehen davon
aus dass nicht alle flieger in jedem
fall voll sein werden und dann wollen
wir das natürlich im sinne der
europäischen solidarität öffnen und das
für andere europäer die in diesen
ländern sind auch die mitnahme dort
ermöglichen
der außenminister ist in vielfältigen
kontakten mit seinen kollegen und da
läuft auch über die krisenstäbe eine
koordinierung dann auch die botschaften
vor ort werden sich koordinieren
da wird vieles tatsächlich ad hoc laufen
das werden die maschinen landen am
flughafen und dann wird man schauen wer
fliegt da jetzt mit ist die maschine
voll wie viele plätze sind noch und dann
nehmen wir selbstverständlich gerne
andere eu-bürger mit schließlich eine
frage von außen von peter carstens mit
an
gibt es zahlen wie viele rückkehrwillige
personen haben sich gemeldet wie viele
können sie das sagen werden heute morgen
ausgeflogen
also die meldungen laufen laufen laufen
bei unserer krisenvorsorge liste elefant
ein ich kann auch nur noch mal dazu
aufrufen sich dort zu melden
wir gehen davon aus dass heute also es
gibt ja auch destinationen wo der
normale flugbetrieb noch läuft und wo
die reiseveranstalter ihre urlauber auch
noch rausholen
wir müssen aber damit rechnen dass es in
den nächsten tagen immer weiter
heruntergefahren wird und dass auch dort
sukzessive womöglich der flugbetrieb zum
erliegen kommt das heißt was wir seit
gestern machen ist mit den
reiseveranstaltern in kontakt sein
gemeinsam mit ihnen in diesem programm
die rückholung zu organisieren
und wir gehen davon aus dass im laufe
des heutigen tages von den carriern die
noch fliegen und sondermaschinen die wir
über lufthansa condor und twittern
ungefähr 30 maschinen in der luft sein
werden um in die besonders getroffen
betroffenen gebiete auszufliegen
wir gehen davon aus dass wir ungefähr
aus ägypten so das sind immer mehrere
einschätzungen das sind viel in
vielfacher hinsicht schätzungen wir
werden es heute abend wissen wir hoffen
dass wir aus ägypten heute abend 4000
personen heraus bekommen und aus der
dominikanischen republik zum beispiel
1500 personen aus marokko rechnen wir
mit 1900 personen das sind so die drei
hotspots wo wir schon ein bisschen
abschätzen können wie genau sieht es aus
bei den anderen ländern sind wir dran
und rechnen die zahlen zusammen das ist
ein großes und so gut wird können werden
wir natürlich auch über den abschluss
der zahlen also über den abfluss aus den
ländern und dass rückkehrer der s rück
kern unserer reisenden auf dem laufenden
halten und informieren ich kann doch
ganz kurz nach liefern das war das erste
mal dass das kabinett im internet so
damit haben wir verschiedene fragen auch
von daniel brössler von der süddeutschen
zu den zahlen rückkehr gibt es noch
fragen rückkehr
das ist nicht der fall dann jung und
dann hat
ich wollte eigentlich das ganze diesen
ganzen asyl kommen wir jetzt machen aber
ich wollte sie eigentlich
hintenanstellen ich schlage vor dass wir
jetzt bei außen bleiben ja können wir so
machen wir das einfach jetzt an die
stelle sind da in dem kontext keine mehr
fragen sind ihr alter es gibt
diesbezüglich an den schengen
aussengrenzen nach meiner kenntnis
bisher keine verfahrens veränderung im
vergleich zu vorgestern
ja das ist er
es gibt ja leitlinien von der
europäischen kommission die sind von aus
brüssel vorgeschlagen worden
darauf haben sich die staats und
regierungschefs gestern verständigt dass
es nach diesen leitlinien in den
schengen staaten einheitlich umgesetzt
wird und in diesen leitlinien sind
ausnahmetatbestände formuliert und diese
ausnahmetatbestände kommen zur anwendung
dann schließlich noch die frage von
janina lücke vom ard hauptstadtstudio an
in diesem kontext
ich glaube die frage zu verfahren die
gestellt wurde ist beantwortet aber da
gab es noch die frage finden spezielle
gesundheits überprüfungen oder
quarantänemaßnahmen bei einreisenden
asylbewerbern stadt oder sind solche
geplant also grundsätzlich ist es so
dass wir bereits in der vergangenen
woche ja die das bundesamt für migration
und flüchtlinge und auch die
ausländerbehörden gebeten haben
neu ankommende schutzsuchende sehr
zeitnah in eine untersuchung zu bringen
in der festgestellt werden kann um
integration für eine etwaige erkrankung
vorliegen das gilt selbstverständlich
auch jetzt und die kontrollen an den
grenzen werden abgestimmt mit dem
örtlich zuständigen gesundheitsamt das
heißt dort gibt es keine vorgaben von
unserer seite auch nicht von der
bundespolizei führung wir sind auch für
so etwas nicht zuständig das zu bewerten
dass da stehen die bundespolizei dienst
stellen an den jeweiligen flughäfen in
kontakt mit dem jeweiligen
gesundheitsamt und dort wird entschieden
kurze zusatzfrage
korrekt dann schließlich an die frage
von außen thomas berling von rtl n-tv
fragt gehört er auch dazu bundespolizei
ausbildungsakademie seien weiterhin
geöffnet polizei und gericht für
polizeischüler findet überwiegend statt
die sind auch dort untergebracht zum
teil in gemeinsamen sanitären
einrichtungen können sie das bestätigen
wenn ja warum werden diese akademien
nicht geschlossen gibt es corona wir
ausfälle an der bundespolizeiakademie
wir haben uns dazu entschieden in denen
in den dienstbetrieb nach prioritäten
bestimmte maßnahmen zu veranlassen das
gilt nicht nur für die bundespolizei
sondern für die gesamte für den gesamten
geschäftsbereich des
bundesinnenministeriums und danach ist
zunächst entschieden worden dass die
fortbildungsmaßnahmen vollständig
eingestellt werden
bei den ausbildungsmaßnahmen haben wir
uns dazu entschieden die zunächst
weiterlaufen zu lassen weil wir die
polizisten brauchen das so zu sagen wenn
man die ausbildung jetzt einstellt und
auf absehbare zeit nicht durchführt die
rahmenbedingungen sind im moment noch so
dass wir das für durchaus machbar halten
dann schiebt man das ausbildungs
geschehen nach hinten und das hat dann
auch viele jahre ja auch auswirkungen im
moment sind die rahmenbedingungen so
dass wir die ausbildung noch durch
durchführen können und sie findet in den
fortbildungszentren der bundespolizei
weiterhin statt
gut dann bleiben wir noch bei diesem
themenkomplex wie gesagt dann finanzen
wirtschaft danach buschow sind auf der
liste aber vorher sind noch andere hair
days zum beispiel
ja das gehört mit in diesem
themenkomplex sein ich will nur
wirtschaft und finanzen dann hinten
anschieben üben also uns haben heute
vormittag auch schon da hat so wieder
eine menge anfragen erreicht deswegen
vielen dank für die frage der sie mir
die gelegenheit geben nur zum ausdruck
zu bringen dass es diese ansprache
keineswegs um die verkündung neuer
maßnahmen geht sondern darum das zu
erklären was in deutschland jetzt zu tun
ist und dass eben mit dem ziel die
ausbreitung des virus zu verlangsamen
und dass daran da sich jeder daran
beteiligen kann
also es geht letztlich darum also das
ziel ist den kontakt zu minimieren und
damit die ausbreitung des virus zu
verlangsamen und das ist die botschaft
die an alle gehen soll
das ist jetzt nicht wenn dann frage und
spekulativ sie macht das jetzt heute mit
dem ziel zu erklären wie uns allen
gemeinsam gelingen kann die ausbreitung
des virus zu verlangsamen und wie sich
jeder von uns daran beteiligen kann
jordan frau lehmann zweck frau lehmann
beantworten oder dazu bitte ich möchte
jetzt erst der fernsehansprache
naturgemäß nicht vorgreifen und ganz
grundsätzlich ist das eine sehr
besondere lage und die hat sich jetzt
dazu entschieden zu diesem zeitpunkt
sich über eine fernsehansprache noch mal
an uns alle zu wenden und insofern
möchte ich ihren worten wir nicht
vorgreifen
grundsätzlich gilt aber natürlich was
ich auch gerade schon gesagt habe wenn
wir das ziel haben die ausbreitung des
virus zu verlangsamen
dann geht es darum den kontakt zu
minimieren und das ist einfach ein
appell an uns alle woran frage zu ob sie
sehen wir machen das hier das kabinett
hat in einem anderen raum getagt also
alleine diese fälle diese social dissing
also den kontakt zu minimieren ist eben
schon eine wichtige maßnahme ansprache
der kanzlerin noch eine frage von muss
bei
ich kann jetzt ich kann jetzt schlecht
eine ansprache der bundeskanzlerin
bewerten und interpretieren bevor sie
sie überhaupt gehalten hat deswegen
würde ich sie bitten sich einfach die
ansprachen anzusehen und ich fange gebe
natürlich hier auch es ist nicht unsere
rolle hier noten zu vergeben
ich erlebe eine bevölkerung die in
vielen teilen sehr sensibel ist es gibt
aber bestimmt auch ausnahmen und
insofern auch hier nochmal ausgesprochen
der appell
das ziel ist es den kontakt zu
minimieren was nie heißt wir leben
lieben einander ab sondern wir gehen auf
distanz und schaffen es so gemeinsam die
ausbreitung des virus zu minimieren
zu diesem themenkomplex noch
ich habe die meldung gesehen ich kann
ihnen dazu gerade vom botschafter in
österreich ich kann ihnen dazu gerade
noch nichts näheres sagen mir liegen
dazu keine erkenntnisse vor
wir hatten am wochenende schon
mitgeteilt dass unter anderem die
ausfuhr von 400.000 schutzmasken nach
italien genehmigt worden war
unter anderem sind auch lieferungen von
schutzausrüstungen in die schweiz
genehmigt worden
auch nach österreich so also dass das
ist alles passiert jetzt zu dem anderen
komplex die da die der
genehmigungsvorbehalt den wir in
deutschland hatten prüfen wir gerade
noch wie sich das verhältnis zum
genehmigungsvorbehalt und zum export
verbot was jetzt die kommission
ihrerseits festgelegt hat da sind wir im
austausch mit der kommission
das schaue ich mir an und mir hat mich
dann gebeten mich okay aber schon noch
zu dem themenkomplex mittel
also beides ist genau genommen nicht der
fall also es gibt keinen neuen stand wir
haben noch den stand den sie kennen und
ich würde jetzt aber auch nicht sagen
dass es auf eis liegt mir ist dazu
einfach im moment keine entscheidung
bekannt
gut dann würde ich vorschlagen wir
wechseln jetzt zu dem themenkomplex
wirtschaft finanzen auch und danach dann
den themenkomplex mit fragen die auch
das verteidigungsministerium noch ins
gesundheitsministerium laufen etliche
fragen auf die die betreffen also gehen
wir da wieder der reihenfolge nach linke
herr blank
das ist die zahl der anträge auf der gds
also zum thema cook kann ich heute keine
aktuellen zahlen liefern ich möchte
vielleicht kurz ein bisschen erklären
wie das erfassen von zahlen läuft es ist
ja so dass unternehmen die von cook aber
profitieren möchten dass anzeigen müssen
bei der bundesagentur für arbeit diese
zahlen werden erfasst
sie liegen aber immer erst dann einen
monat nach laufenden vor das sind auch
erstmal nur anzeigen das sagt noch
nichts über die frage wie viele
beschäftigten tatsächlich guckt in
anspruch genommen haben
diese zahlen liegen immer erst drei
monate nach laufend vor
wir können sagen wir sind natürlich mit
der pa in regem austausch wir hören
natürlich auch über die b aa aus den
agenturen vor ort dass es momentan eine
einen enormen anstieg an beratungsbedarf
gibt die agenturen sind da wirklich rund
um die uhr bemüht diesen beratungsbedarf
zu erfüllen
es gibt auch eine ganze reihe von
unternehmen die guckt jetzt erstmals in
anspruch nehmen wollen die natürlich
auch noch keine erfahrung mit diesem
instrument haben auch hier berät die
bundesagentur für arbeit umfassend und
ich kann eigentlich nur ermuntern sich
über dieses ganze thema kurzarbeitergeld
auf der internetseite der bahn
informieren da gibt es wirklich
umfassendes sehr verständliches material
wer anspruch hat wie die voraussetzungen
sind wo beantragt werden kann und so
weiter genau zu dem weiteren hilfen die
wir im bereich liquidität steuerstundung
und so weiter gibt es auch umfassende
informationen sowohl
bundesfinanzministerium als das beim
bundeswirtschaftsministerium die beiden
minister haben ja am freitag dazu
informiert das läuft jetzt an die
kfw hat heute zusammen mit der deutschen
kreditwirtschaft details zu dieser
liquiditätsversorgung bekannt gegeben
und hat auch auf ihrer internetseite
umfängliche informationen dazu da möchte
ich noch mal betonen dass diese mittel
jetzt sofort zur verfügung stehen und
über die hausbanken ausgezahlt werden
können es wurden auch vereinfachungen
angekündigt von der kfw das ist jetzt
alles zügig geht oder ich möchte auch
noch mal betonen weil das ja immer
wieder auch die frage ist dass diese
hilfen für alle gelten also auch für
selbstständige und freiberufler
und wie gesagt informationen zu den
details gibt es sowohl bei den
ministerien als auch bei der kaffee auf
der website
kaffee ist auch eine hotline zu dem
thema geschaltet um alle zu informieren
dass es diese hilfen jetzt auch zeitnah
ausgezahlt werden können
[Musik]
genau der minister hat jetzt zusammen
mit dem wirtschaftsminister in der
pressekonferenz dieses hilfspaket
angekündigt und wichtig ist für uns die
aussage dass allen geholfen wird die
liquiditätshilfen sind ja unbegrenzt es
wurde gleichzeitig aber auch immer vom
minister betont auch in seinen
statements jetzt nach dieser
pressekonferenz dass es wichtig ist dass
gegebenenfalls noch nach gesteuert wird
da wo hilfe notwendig ist und dass die
hilfe zielgerichtet ankommt er hat auch
von der möglichkeit gesprochen einen
nothilfefonds einzurichten da laufen
jetzt die arbeiten sobald details
feststehen werden wir hier informieren
wichtig ist eben das ziel dass wir gut
durch die krise kommen und dass wir alle
notwendigen maßnahmen ergreifen und wie
wir ja auch betont haben die notwendigen
mittel dafür sind da
das wird sehr schnell werden so zügig
wie möglich informationen dazu
bekanntgeben
ich schrieb dazu auch noch eine frage
von außen 1 von hannes koch
ob es für freiberufler künstler solo
selbständige eine grundsicherung geben
wird fragen werden firmen
direktzahlungen oder transfers so hätten
etwa als negative einkommensteuer über
die finanzämter ja eben schon betonen
wichtig ist für uns dass die hilfen
zielgerichtet alle erreichen
für die sie notwendig sind wir haben
bereits massnahmen vorgestellt so weit
weitere maßnahmen erforderlich sind wenn
wir die zügig vorstellen der laufen im
moment die überlegung und sobald das
details gibt werden wir sie bekanntgeben
und noch einmal der hinweis dass die
liquiditätshilfen die wir dazu gesagt
haben dass die unabhängig von der größe
des unternehmens auch für selbstständige
bilden kann vielleicht kurz nochmal
ergänzen und gerne nochmal auf den auf
das interview mit deshalb heute morgen
im morgenmagazin verweisen da hat er ja
auch genau auf diese frage beantwortet
und sozusagen seinerseits auch
angekündigt dass er möchte das auch
selbstständiger einfachen und
unbürokratischen zugang zum zur
grundsicherung erhalten
daran arbeiten wir jetzt ebenfalls busse
jordaans so exakt wie jordan social
hessen hätte
nach den ersten teil den zweiten habe
ich nicht so richtig verstanden aber zum
ersten teil kann nicht sagen
oder kann ich nochmal auf das verweisen
was der minister gesagt hat es geht ihm
um einen einfachen unbürokratischen
zugang auch für selbstständige zum thema
grundsicherung das ist nicht zu
verwechseln mit einem bedingungslosen
grundeinkommen das bedingungslose
grundeinkommen ist auch aus rechtlicher
sicht
aus unserer sicht hier nicht die
richtige antwort weil man nicht eine
bestimmte gruppe einer bestimmten gruppe
ein solches grundeinkommen zur verfügung
stellen kann und andere ausschließen
kann
insofern bleibt es dabei was der
minister angekündigt hat heute morgen
frau zusatz
dafür werden wir glaube ich aber zu
ständig wechseln das ministerium dann
ist frau bus dann ein paar kreutzmann
herr lange ihr habt eine frage ja dann
ja aber in der reihenfolge und ich werde
ich wäre dankbar wenn wir das so halten
können ja es ist alles etwas woide ich
bitte einfach um verständnis dass das
hier unter etwas anderen und etwas
komplexen bedingungen stattfindet und
ich werde auch dankbar wenn sich
einzelne medien die doppelt vertreten
sind abstimmen können untereinander so
jetzt ist das justizministerium haben
das könnt ihr schon erklären
[Musik]
also ich kann ihnen zu ihrer frage
mitteilen dass genau das bfv derzeit
möglichkeiten prüft wie mieterinnen und
mieter die in folge der krone corona
krise in finanzielle schwierigkeiten
kommen sind vor dem verlust einer
mietwohnung geschützt werden können
das gilt sowohl für mieterinnen und
mieter von wohnraum ebenso wie für
gewerbe mieterinnen und mieter und genau
das loch jetzt gerade die prüfungen und
werden die möglichkeiten ausgelotet
gut dann folgte schon
dann bleibt sie ist jetzt genau jetzt
minister bleibt das können wir
gegenwärtig noch nicht genau festlegen
wir ich kann ihnen sagen dass wir in
alle richtungen prüfen und uns die
optionen anschauen und genau wir sind
jetzt gerade noch in den anfängen
deshalb kann ich das jetzt noch nicht
festlegen dann ein kreuz machen herr
lange hessen
[Musik]
wo stehen kann die scheiße dass sie den
streaming angeboten
das etwas was der stadt aufkläre
oder dass man gestiegen damit bin ich
jetzt ehrlich gesagt über fragt ich weiß
nicht ob das eher eine frage ans
ministerium für verkehr und
infrastruktur wäre nein
dann müsste ich ihnen das erreichen
okay dann haben wir lange
[Musik]
gehört haben erläutert dass die
massnahmen ständig angepasst werden an
die notwendigkeiten die sich entwickeln
das gilt natürlich auch für das kfw
programm da sind jetzt erste
informationen rausgegangen natürlich
wird das weiterhin beobachtet was jetzt
noch weiter zu tun ist oder wo
anpassungen vorzunehmen sind
zu den eckwerten da läuft jetzt das
normale haushaltsverfahren das auch
notwendig ist natürlich um auch einen
ausblick zu haben wie der bundeshaushalt
in den folgenden jahren aussehen wird im
haushalt selber konnten die auswirkungen
von corinna natürlich noch nicht
berücksichtigt werden das ist ja noch
gar keine konjunkturindikatoren da ist
auch noch nicht bekannt wie groß die
programme werden und wie groß die in
anspruch genommen werden die wir jetzt
aufgelegt haben
deswegen haben wir auch in der
pressemitteilung auch in der
kommunikation gesagt das dann natürlich
dann anpassungen notwendig sind sind
jetzt erstmal die eckwerte das ist das
worauf sich die regierung verständigt
hat wir werden dann wie immer im sommer
einen regierungsentwurf vorlegen da sind
dann natürlich anpassungen drin im
hinblick auf die veränderte lage die wir
jetzt haben und auch im
parlamentarischen verfahren sind immer
noch anpassungen möglich und wie immer
wird dann der haushalt im dezember
verabschiedet und bis dahin wird
sicherlich noch einige änderungen geben
noch mal betonen möchte ich aber es geht
um den haushalt 2021 also die auswirkung
jetzt erstmal vorüber wir jetzt erst mal
reden ist er zu 20 und da haben wir die
finanzielle kraft alle maßnahmen zu
stemmen die jetzt notwendig sind gut
essen herr der ringe jung
ich habe eben betont dass die gespräche
auch zu weiteren maßnahmen laufen
bestimmen uns natürlich eng innerhalb
der bundesregierung abgestimmte uns ab
auch mit den bundesländern die
finanzministerkonferenz wird
zusammenkommen auch mit dem
bundesfinanzminister um über diese
themen zu sprechen wie reagiert man
jetzt auf die krise um möglichst gut auf
die herausforderungen zu reagieren
natürlich auch über das hinaus was mit
den ländern zu besprechen ist sind wir
auch einem koordinierten vorgehen auf
europäischer und internationaler ebene
interessiert der minister hat
teilgenommen an der euro-gruppe am
montag auch da läuft ein koordiniertes
verfahren und auch auf internationaler
ebene ist man jetzt regelmäßig g7 g20 im
gespräch sie sehen die maßnahmen werden
koordiniert und wir werden uns zudem mit
allen länderfinanzministerien und
länderfinanzminister abstimmen
die bleibt bei dem was ich gesagt habe
wir stimmen uns eng mit unseren partnern
ab und werden auch weitere maßnahmen
dann zusammen bekanntgeben ich könnte
was nachrechnen zu den streaming
diensten ja da würde ich sie bitten sich
an die benutzer zu wenden die es dazu im
ständigen austausch mit den
telekommunikationsanbietern dann haben
wir haben tipps und tricks
er findet eigentlich kann nur noch mal
wiederholen was ich eben schon gesagt
habe wir sind zu allen diesen maßnahmen
im gespräch und sobald details
feststehen werden wir uns dazu äußern
auf europäischer ebene haben die
europäischen finanzministerien und
finanzminister am montag ein statement
abgegeben wir werden auch mit den
finanzministern und finanzministerien
der länder ein statement abgeben was
jetzt an maßnahmen koordiniert geplant
wird und was die bundesregierung dazu
beizutragen hat haben wir am freitag
gesagt auch das wird natürlich
anzupassen seien an die jeweils
erforderliche lage zum minister selber
der hat ja heute ein foto gepostet wie
er auf seinem balkon sitzt und jetzt
seine arbeit aus dem homeoffice erfüllt
das ist eine sicherheitsmaßnahme auch
für die mitarbeiterinnen und mitarbeiter
er ist wie ich auch schon gesagt habe
weiterhin mit seinen kolleginnen auf
landes- und auch auf internationaler
ebene im gespräch
er wird an der finanzministerkonferenz
die als telefonkonferenz durchgeführt
wird teilnehmen er wird an der
[Musik]
sitzung der finanzministerin und
finanzminister auf eu-ebene dem ecofin
am freitag teilnehmen die als video
konferenz erfolgt also von daher ist er
steht voll im saft und nimmt seine
aufgaben wahr
wir hoffen dass das heute der fall ist
dass wir heute eine rückmeldung kriegen
linke und dann könnten wir viele noch
dazu kommt dann noch und dann würde ich
vorschlagen wechseln
genau da gilt das gleiche was ich eben
schon gesagt habe wir haben maßnahmen
beschlossen umfassende maßnahmen
unbegrenzt der liquiditätshilfen wir
haben auf eu ebene ein großes
maßnahmenpaket mit den finanzministerien
und finanzministern verkündet auf
landesebene mit den finanzministern und
finanzministern der länder werden wir
ein gemeinsames ab gemeinsames verfahren
finden wie wir weitere maßnahmen auf den
weg bringen und die diskussionen laufen
und es wird alles getan um gut durch
diese krise zu kommen und dafür werden
wir die erforderlichen maßnahmen treffen
dann vielleicht noch als ergänzung ich
habe eben gesagt möglicherweise gibt es
heute noch ein ergebnis
ich wurde gerade korrigiert das ergebnis
kommt wahrscheinlich morgen
ich möchte vielleicht auch noch mal ganz
kurz ergänzen zum thema grundsicherung
die wir in deutschland haben ein
funktionierendes system der
existenzsicherung und das funktioniert
auch weiter alle leistungen werden
bezahlt die bundesagentur bewilligt auch
neue anträge also weil sie auch fragten
jenseits der selbstständigkeit wir haben
hier ein funktionierendes system das
auch unter diesen umständen weiter
funktioniert so herr jung noch eine
frage die auch wirtschaft und finanzen
treffen und dann könnten wir wechseln
und es gibt eine reihe von fragen die
betreffen besonders
gesundheitsministerium und haben kollatz
verteidigungsministeriums
[Musik]
für uns ist wichtig dass die hilfen
schnell ankommen die unser programm
wurde am freitag hier verkündet und
heute deswegen hab ich das sehr betont
heute sind die information der kfw an
die banken gegangen deswegen jetzt
glaube ich ihr informationsstand da
überholt also diese informationen sind
jetzt bei den banken und die banken aus
banken können jetzt darauf reagieren ist
natürlich klar das was sie ausgeführt
haben gilt natürlich auch er selbst auch
für uns viele sind jetzt im home-office
man muss jetzt anders arbeiten wir
arbeiten jetzt hier anders sieht man an
der sitzordnung die europäischen
finanzminister tagen der video konferenz
also es müssen jetzt andere abläufe her
und das erfordert im moment einige oder
führt zu einigen
umstellungsschwierigkeiten wir denken
aber dass das alles schnell in den griff
bekommen werden kann und dass dann diese
hilfen auch bei denen ankommen und zwar
zügig die sie benötigen
ich würde ein kolberger gerne nochmal
ganz allgemein unterstützen
also ich glaube es ist ganz klar dass
die bundesregierung gemeinsam mit den
ländern ein großes bestreben hat
die probleme die durch eine nie
dagewesene herausfordernde lage
entstehen möglichst schnell zu lösen und
das gewährleisten ist die hilfe bei
allen diese brauchen möglichst schnell
ankommt dass das nicht ganz reibungslos
laufen kann und sofort aber ich sie
sehen mit welcher also been in welchem
zeitrahmen wir hier schon entscheidungen
beschlossen haben maßnahmen beschlossen
haben und möchte einfach nur noch mal
darauf hinweisen also der wille ist da
und wir geben alles und manches wird
möglicherweise nicht ganz reibungslos
und in sekundenschnelle erledigt seien
systemrelevant verstehe ich jetzt nicht
so richtig was ist die frage
da hat er eben frau dann auch zu
ausgeführt dass wir mit den ländern im
gespräch sind wie dann die hilfen auch
aussehen für die betreuung und so weiter
da haben sie bitte verständnis dass das
auch alles läuft und wie ich auch
ausgeführt habe es muss jetzt natürlich
auch andere möglichkeiten geben wie man
im home-office diese sachen erledigen
kann das bmf ist jetzt zum großen teil
im home-office um diese aufgaben zu
erledigen und deswegen ist im grunde das
habe ich ja schon ausgeführt wenn uns
alle die herausforderungen die abläufe
anders zu gestalten um eben die
ansteckung zu verzögern
damit unser gesundheitssystem mit dieser
herausforderung zurechtkommt die banken
sind gut aufgestellt
finanziell und der bundeshaushalt ist
ebenfalls gut aufgestellt wir sind
vorbereitet und wir können diese krise
stemmen und die firma ausgeführt hat
jetzt müssen alle an einem strang ziehen
und da wird es vielleicht an der einen
oder anderen stelle mal hakeln aber bis
jetzt denke ich dass die sachen die wir
auf den weg gebracht haben sehr sehr
schnell funktioniert haben und die
möglichkeit da ist jetzt sehr schnell
hilfe an die zu bringen die sie brauchen
sodann jetzt noch eine frage von außen
ans finanzministerium von herrn
kreutzfeldt warum kann der
finanzminister getestet werden wenn er
nur eine erkältung hat als normaler
bürger wird man in seinem in einem
solchen fall nicht getestet oder liege
ich fragt der creutzfeldt da falsch wie
die voraussetzung für die testung sind
kann sicherlich das
gesundheitsministerium ausführen
ich denke dass jeder verständnis haben
wird dass wir schnell wissen müssen
ob der finanzminister und vizekanzler
gesund ist wie wir das annehmen und
nicht infiziert ist weil dann ja weitere
maßnahmen notwendig werden würden und da
sind wir dabei das schnell zu klären
nehmen wir das zum anlass und wechseln
und ich würde sagen gesundheits und
verteidigungsministerium kommen nach
vorne
die schließt dann schon mal fragen an
von außen also dieses stichwort testen
wie läuft das eigentlich mehrfach
angesprochen
ja ich gebe dann gleich noch andere
fragen von außen rein die gesundheit auf
betreffen also ich werde jetzt keinen
einzelfall kommentieren
dass es dann letztendlich die
entscheidung des arztes ob er testet
oder nicht oder das gesundheitsamt aus
pop r testet oder nicht dafür gibt es
einen einfluss schema was das rk ii
entwickelt hat und danach richten sich
die ärzte die das sind jetzt dem
konkreten fall ist kann ich nicht
nachvollziehen und auch nicht nicht
kommentieren schiebe ich noch die frage
nach wann also die veröffentlichung
zeigen wie wichtig die wohn test zahlen
bei leichten symptomen sind um die
ausbreitung von gofit 19 zu stoppen
in der zeit wird derzeit aber nur
getestet wer schwere symptome hat und
kontakt zu einem infizierten wann ist
damit zu rechnen dass die tests in
deutschland deutlich ausgeweitet werden
das ist nicht korrekt
also wäre
persönlichen kontakt hat zu einem hatte
zu einem infizierten soll sich ans
gesundheitsamt wenden
wer in risikogebieten war soll möglichst
zu hause bleiben und wenn er dann
symptome entwickelt soll er sich an
seinen arzt oder das gesundheitsamt
wenden wie gesagt die einzelfall
entscheidungen trifft immer der arzt
aber es gibt eine klare klare maßgabe
wie tests auch zu bezahlen durchzuführen
es gibt also nicht jetzt einen grund es
nicht zu machen aber nicht jeder muss
sich testen lassen auch das ist wahr
gut dann herr blank hessen
ich kann das auch machen also sonst ja
also zu dem grobkonzept infrastruktur
krankenhaus das ist beschlossen worden
worden
bei einer runde des chef des
bundeskanzleramtes mit den chefs der
staatskanzleien der länder
das soll so schnell umgesetzt werden wie
möglich wir versuchen eine
doppelstrategie durch die ganzen
maßnahmen um soziale kontakte zu
vermeiden versuchen wir möglichst die
kurve über die wir schon mehrfach
gesprochen haben abzuflachen
also dafür zu sorgen dass ich möglichst
wenig leute infizieren dass wir die
ausbreitung des virus zu verhindern und
gleichzeitig versuchen wir die intensiv
kapazitäten aufzustocken um uns
vorzubereiten auf auf mehr
das gesundheitswesen vorzubereiten auf
einen höheren anzahl von patienten auch
intensivpatienten
woher kommen die ärzte ist es
ist in diesem konzept ein punkt drin
vorhandenes personal zusätzlich zu
schulen also es wird gesagt voraus dass
die kliniken werden aufgefordert
forscher haben personalplanungen jetzt
zu betreiben also sich auf diesen fall
einzustellen
vorhandenes personal zusätzlich zu
schulen
dann aus anderen bereichen für den
intensivbereich konzepte zu entwickeln
für den einsatz von medizinstudenten
studenten höherer semester sowie für den
einsatz von ärzten und pflegekräften die
aus dem ruhestand oder anderen bereichen
zur unterstützung zur verfügung stellen
wenn ich den kabinettsbeschluss in
bayern gestern richtig gelesen habe ist
das genau das was was gemacht wird die
geschichte mit dem mundschutz mit dem
artenschutz da sagen uns die
wissenschaftler das ist für den
alltagsgebrauch nicht sinnvoll
nein das sind die aktuellen zahlen aber
wir arbeiten mit hochdruck daran diese
zahlen zu erhöhen
diesem ziel dient ja dass das ist
christa gestern erarbeitet worden ist
also kurz gesagt eine verdoppelung wäre
das ziel und die länder sind gebeten
worden diese pläne auszuarbeiten
er ist ein unternehmer antwort zur
ersten frage zurzeit nicht also ist
wenig bekannt
zweite frage herr wähler hat heute eine
zahl von 160.000 tests die pro woche
gemacht werden
sie wissen krankenhausplanung ist
ländersache
also die länder müssen diese konzepte
erarbeiten die chefs der staatskanzleien
der länder waren auch an der erarbeitung
dieses konzeptes beteiligt und das
müssen jetzt ausarbeiten und klar
die können sich dann an die landes-
entsprechenden landes institutionen
wenden und wie die das regeln
hoffentlich bald
ja das hat der minister wiederholt
gesagt
aber auch da sind wir mit hochdruck
dabei abhilfe zu schaffen
wir haben ich weiß gar nicht wann vor
zwei will ich mich jetzt nicht festlegen
aber schon von länger zeit begonnen
zentral schutzausrüstung zu beschaffen
medizinische schutzausrüstung zu
beschaffen
auch zentral intensivmedizinische
kapazitäten auch zu kaufen
und da sind wir mit hochdruck dabei und
denken auch in den nächsten tagen da
weiterzukommen
also wir sprechen hier wie schnell wird
er behoben wir sprechen da von von nicht
von wochen sondern von tagen
und mir ist jetzt es gibt meldungen von
kliniken die schwierigkeiten haben die
sich melden es gibt meldungen auch von
einzelnen ärzten und arztpraxen die
sagen sie kriegen aber mir ist jetzt
nicht bekannt dass in großem maße
irgendwie einen arztpraxen vom netz
gehen würden oder stationen von beziehen
bin gut dann schrieb ich noch mal von
außen die fragen ein
in ähnlicher weise von norbert wallet
von der stuttgarter zeitung und von
kristina dunz von der rheinischen post
das bezieht sich auf ausgangs stellen
kristina dunz sagt wenn wie vom
robert-koch-institut vorausgesagt die
zahl der infizierten in den nächsten
drei monaten auf zehn millionen steigt
von welchen punkt also zahl der
infizierten an etwa werden die maßnahmen
verschärft oder zum beispiel die
ausgangssperren beraten und norbert
wallet fragt wenn es also der das
bezieht sich ausnahme zu gut dass es
noch etwas anderes weiß nicht ob man da
was dazu sagen kann wenn es zu weiteren
verschärfungen
fragt mal ausnahmezustand kommt wäre das
nur im rahmen wäre das wieder so dass
das von den bundesländern
unterschiedlich konkretisiert werden
muss oder gibt es eine handhabe
einheitliche vorgaben über den umfang
und ausnahmen zu machen
ich habe mich zu diesem punkt ja auch in
der vergangenen regierung
pressekonferenz schon geäußert ich kann
jetzt nicht maßnahmen vorwegnehmen die
möglicherweise in ein zwei drei vier
fünf wochen notwendig sein werden die
bundesregierung passt der lage folgend
und dem rat der experten folgen tiere
maßnahmen immer aktuell an
ein zweiter deshalb ist es ja das bezog
sich auf den begriff auf einem
ausnahmezustand und die frage ob er zwar
stärkere möglichkeiten gibt dass
bundeseinheitlich zufolge klare bemühen
ist ja dass im gesamten bundesgebiet die
regelungen einheitlich sind deswegen
gibt es inzwischen täglich schalten mit
den ländern der
chef des kanzleramtes ist helge braun
jeden tag mit den cds der länder und es
wird auch immer wieder schallten mit den
ministerpräsidenten geben mit dem ziel
dort gemeinsam lösungen zu finden und
bislang ist es ich darf da nochmal
ergänzen diese zahl der wähler heute
gesagt hat es dabei handelt sich um eine
eine wissenschaftliche modulation das
hat ja auch gesagt in seinen
ausführungen die sind diese zahlen sind
mit vorsicht zu genießen und das hat ja
auch mehrfach vorher schon betont auch
andere länder haben solche zahlen
herausgegeben klar ist dass die zahl der
intensivpatienten stark steigen wird wie
stark hängt vom verhalten der menschen
ab hängt davon ab wie die maßnahmen
greifen die wir gut dann habe ich jetzt
zu diesen themen noch auf der liste
haben jordaans herrn jungen frau buschel
herrn lange und dann würde ich
vorschlagen wechseln wir zu den fragen
wie auch bmvg betreffen auch dann zu den
auslandseinsätzen dem kabinett thema
waren also herr jordan
warum also zu den zahlen wir haben
natürlich beide zahlen im blick aber das
robert-koch-institut hat ja sehr
transparent gemacht warum sie diese
zahlen hat sie verlässt sich auf zahlen
die nicht irgendwie gemeldet werden
sondern wirklich labor geprüfte zahlen
darauf musste sich verlassen die
elektronisch gemeldet sind um sie zu
verarbeiten und am anfang haben die halt
noch sämtliche fälle berücksichtigt das
können sie jetzt bei dieser anzahl der
fälle nicht mehr machen
sämtliche sämtliche meldungen im blick
haben die auch anderweitig reinkommen
auch pressemeldungen haben die früher
ausgewertet und solche sachen
das ist dass es zu unsicher sie
verlassen sich oft labor fälle labor
geprüfte fälle aber wir haben natürlich
von dem institut was sie gerade genannt
haben natürlich die zahlen auch bei der
bewertung der lage in einen blick und
kompetenzen lassen kann das
innenministerium muss dazu sagen also
zumindest zu dem teil der unterbringung
von den flüchtlingen in den
gemeinschaftsunterkünften kann ich ihnen
sagen das ist rein kompetenz rechtlich
betrachtet eine sache der länder
das heißt sie sind zuständig für die
versorgung natürlich auch für die
eventuell notwendige medizinische
versorgung
ich will aber vielleicht bei der
gelegenheit nochmal sagen
das in vielen fragen die auch dazu
gestellt werden so ein bisschen
unterschwellig mitschwingt dass das ein
nachteil sei dass man das nicht zentral
hier machen kann
wir erleben in dem was wir beurteilen an
vielen stellen dass es auch ein großer
vorteil ist dass wir die ganzen dinge
die jetzt zu klären und zu regeln sind
nicht zentral aus berlin entscheiden
müssen sondern dass die zum teil eben
oder zu großen teilen dezentral in den
ländern beurteilt und gehandhabt werden
weil wir natürlich nur bedingt
einschätzen können was vor ort dringend
notwendig ist bei all dem steht aber
immer die sozusagen bereitschaft des
bundes die länder auch im notwendigen
umfang zu unterstützen wenn die
unterstützung notwendig ist
ja ich kann es kurz machen für die frage
zu obdachlosen menschen gilt im prinzip
das gleiche auch hier liegt die
zuständigkeit bei den ländern und
kommunen
sodann dazu so der nächste herr jung
dann fruscio
also soweit ich das denn den
ausführungen auch von einem wähler
entnehmen konnte ist es so dass es dabei
um aggregierter anonymisierte daten geht
das dient dem zweck umzuschauen
bewegungs nicht bewegungsprofile sondern
insgesamt die bewegung sich anzuschauen
der bevölkerung und dann zu sehen ob die
maßnahmen greifen wenn ich ihn richtig
verstanden habe aber das ist eine sache
die sie dann auch letztendlich dass das
rk ii fragen müssen wir begrüßen auf
jeden fall wenn man wenn man evaluieren
kann ob die maßnahmen greifen oder nicht
aber das werden sie auch
spätestens in zwei wochen werden sie das
ohnehin wissen ich weiß nicht ob das
dazugehört frage von außen von herrn
kreis kann die bundesregierung details
zu einer anwendung nennen um die
standortdaten von infizierten zu nutzen
wird das gefragt nein das kann ich nicht
das ist auch im bereich des robert koch-
institut das sind erste
wissenschaftliche ansätze die sich damit
damit befassen aber da ist bislang
nichts weiteres geplant foto häring
erlangen und herr rinke und dann sind
wir mit dem themenkomplex durch
naja wir versuchen schon auf fake news
zu reagieren und sind darauf aufmerksam
gemacht worden
durch eine türkische kollegin von ihnen
haben das überprüft und diese fake news
am in der tat relativ hohe klickzahlen
erreicht und da haben wir gedacht da
müssen wir das gegen setzen um das
richtigzustellen ich will jetzt die fake
news nicht wiederholen aber die sind so
absurd dass man da auf jeden fall was
machen musste ich kann das noch ergänzen
also das ist auch unser bestreben
möglichst in möglichst vielen sprachen
die informationen der gesamten
bevölkerung zugänglich zu machen auch
den bevölkerungsteilen die
möglicherweise der deutschen sprache
nicht ganz mächtig sind lange inkl
nein das habe ich nicht wir haben gesagt
wir wollen dass in einem ersten schritt
verdoppeln
sie sehen an den an den massnahmen
gestern berlin zum beispiel dass die
länder auch die zeichen der zeit erkannt
hatten haben dann entsprechend ausrüsten
und aufrüsten
das ist jetzt auch nicht so dass das wir
sagen verdopplung und dann reicht das ja
dass das ist nicht so sondern wir müssen
jetzt da hinkommen umzuschalten und die
zahl der intensiv kapazitäten deutlich
zu erhöhen
[Musik]
das brauchen sie gar nicht weil ich
meine in solchen zeiten wo die nachfrage
so hoch ist regelt dass der markt wir
beschaffen jetzt erst mal relativ
schnell diese schutzmasken sind einige
verträge unterschrieben und das habe ich
ja schon vorher gesagt mit welchen zeit
also was wir nach dieser nach dieser
geschichte machen nach dieser krise
machen das steht auf einem anderen blatt
wie man dafür sorgt dass man bei solchen
schutzausrüstung nicht abhängig ist von
von einer globalisierten wirtschaft
das ist eine frage die man sich dann
nach dieser krise stellt vielleicht
hatte ich ergänzen da ja unser
beschaffungsamt mit der federführung im
auftrag des bmg beauftragt ist eben auch
diese schaffung maßnahmen die hand zu
nehmen damit wir uns nicht gegenseitig
konkurrenz machen kann ich ihnen sagen
dass innerhalb von 24 stunden schon
mehrere verträge abgeschlossen wurden
nach beauftragung und derzeit 33
verträge mit einer laufzeit die
lieferung vorsieht ende dieses monats
abgeschlossen wurden von etwa 224
millionen euro die eben auch die
schutzausstattung betrifft da arbeiten
wir eng mit der generaldirektion
zusammen die hier allein elf verträge
abgeschlossen hat und die lieferzeiten
sind nach meinem verständnis keineswegs
lang sondern erst die dinge sind schon
zugelaufen und werden an das bmg gegeben
und bis mitte april werden alle dieser
verträge erfüllt sein
das ist tages abhängig so
unterschiedlich dass ich da nicht
festlegen möchte ich kann ihn aber gerne
tagesaktuelle zahlen nach liefern aber
ich kann auch noch mal darauf hinweisen
dass ja auch unsere ministerinnen sie
eingeladen hat morgen 13 uhr hier an
dieser stelle einer pressekonferenz
teilzunehmen und dort werden sie
sicherlich auch noch einige details
machte sich genau in der regel schon
beantwortet wurde es gab von außen auf
die frage wie das mit den export
regelungen für die masten und
schutzgüter ist ob solche in deutschland
knappen schutzgüter nach wie vor
exportiert werden dass ich war schon
gesagt okay dann auch an denen
fragesteller von außen das hatte ich
jetzt nicht im blick ist beantwortet
dann gehen darüber
dollar zwar dran und wir kommen jetzt zu
fragen zum themenkomplex
bundeswehreinsätze mali herr im moment
jetzt
ich gehe gerne anfangen also was die
einsätze angeht treffen das natürlich
ins beim kontingentwechsel phasen die
zeiträume wie wir zu wechseln haben ich
kann hier keine generelle regel bekannt
geben wie sich die änderung auf die
einsätze natürlich ergeben das ist
abhängig von den vorgaben des einsatz
landes wie es dort mit medizinischen
maßnahmen aussieht es ist abhängig davon
wie die jeweiligen einsatz führenden vor
ort das sind ja nicht immer nur deutsche
sondern das sind ja auch andere nationen
die dort die führung haben die vorgaben
machen und das ist davon abhängig wie
auch kapazitäten an unterkunft vor ort
zur verfügung stehen um gegebenenfalls
in das einsatzland kommende kontingente
zunächst in eine quarantäne zu bringen
das sind die faktoren die ich nenne im
einsatz weil von afghanistan als
beispiel ist es so dass wir dort
unterkunftskapazitäten haben und geben
falls dann vor ort menschen die neu
reinkommen in quarantäne bringen und
erst danach den wechsel machen
das führt dann im einzelfall dazu das
personal länger im einsatz bleibt oder
später reinkommt aber es hat keinerlei
auswirkungen auf die mandats getreue
wahrnehmung der aufgaben vor ort
so kann ja das sind ja nato-einsatz
mittel und auch am nato einsatz der dort
anfang steht da bitte ich sie sich an
die nato zu wenden was touch und erbil
angeht ist es tatsächlich so dass ja im
moment die ausbildung eingestellt ist im
zentralirak aufgrund von corvette 19 und
ihr natürlich auch auf täglicher basis
ist eine gefahrenanalyse machen und das
personal was in erbil moment
entschuldigung intouch im moment nicht
in die ausbildung eingebunden ist dann
natürlich abziehen und in den norden
bringen wo es bessere bedingungen
vorfindet das ist der grund für die den
abzug zunächst aus touch so da machen
jetzt genau aus grundsätzlich zu dem
bericht der soll eben dazu dienen den
bundestag umfassend über die lage in der
region und unsere deutsches engagement
zu informieren
wir beabsichtigen grundsätzlich maly bei
seinen anstrengungen auf dem weg zu
einem demokratischen und stabileren
staat weiterhin zu unterstützen und
dabei verfolgen wir und das soll auch so
bleiben einen vernetzten ansatz der
sicherheitspolitik der
entwicklungspolitik sowie stabilisierung
und humanitäre hilfe wir gehen auch in
unserem engagement davon aus dass
langfristig nur eine dauerhafte
politische lösung
stabile stabilität in die region bringt
die auch wirklich hält sie hatten
gefragt was unsere lage einschätzung ist
wir haben in den letzten monaten
grenzüberschreitende dschihadistische
angriffe in diesen drei länder gebiet
mali burkina faso und niger gesehen und
die haben auch zugenommen
ziel und opfer dieser angriffe sind
dabei sowohl die zivilbevölkerung als
auch staatliche einrichtungen sowie
polizei und militär basen und gerade
auch die jüngsten entwicklungen zeigen
uns wie wichtig unser engagement in der
region und auch genau dort ist denn wir
sind uns da habe ich alle bewusst dass
ein
internationaler einsatz zur
stabilisierung langfristig angelegt ist
und auch einen langen atem erfordert
davon gehen wir aus aber dieser region
ist für europa aus den verschiedensten
gründen ebenso wichtig dass wir uns dort
weiter engagieren wollen was ihr aber
auch tun wollen und das werden sie dann
auch in dem bericht oder das wird im
bundestag auch berichtet ist dass wir
den anteil der sicherheitsverantwortung
denen die nachbarn denen diese ganze
region für sich selbst trägt erhöhen
wollen und die staaten auch in die lage
versetzen wollen sich selber zu
befähigen und selber zu helfen
in diesem rahmen sind wir ja bisher
schon in den missionen engagiert na ja
wir hatten eine solche reise ja nicht
angekündigt
danke für die frage ganz kurz vorweg
korrektur ich habe eben glaube ich
fälschlicherweise gesagt dass für
afghanistan die quarantäne in
afghanistan vorgesehen das ist falsch
sie ist in deutschland vorgesehen erst
dann geht das kontingent personal nach
afghanistan rein das zur richtigstellung
irgendwas die errichtung eines
krankenhauses eines zeltes zur
wahrnehmung von medizinischen aufgaben
in berlin angeht kann ich bestätigen
dass es dort informelle vorabsprachen
gibt mit unserem kommando territoriale
aufgaben
das ist mit dem berliner senats erfolgt
diese vorabsprachen ein formelles
amtshilfeersuchen in dem sinne gibt es
dazu noch nicht
ich kann ihnen aber so viel sagen dass
es da seitens der leistung der
bundeswehr um tatkräftige hände geht die
beim aufbau unterstützen darüber hinaus
gibt es keine festlegungen oder
absprachen und konkret für weitere
bauliche anforderungen liegen mir keine
informationen vor
diese frage wird auch von außen jetzt
vermehrt gestellt da scheint meldungen
zu geben ja das ist zutreffend
das bundesinnenministerium hat das
bauamt gestern gebeten das resettlement
verfahren im rahmen des 11 mechanismus
mit der türkei als auch die resettlement
programme des bundes einstweilig
einzustellen
aufgrund der beschränkung im
reiseverkehr und auch bei den wichtigen
partnern unter anderem auch ios die im
laufe der letzten tage eingetreten sind
sind die programme faktisch ohnehin
schon vergangenen freitag zum erliegen
gekommen und sie werden wieder
aufgenommen sobald das faktisch möglich
ist es geht um die resettlement
programme die der bund also die beim
bund laufen und unter anderem ist eines
auch das resettlement verfahren im
rahmen des 11 mechanismus mit der türkei
alle programme des bundes jahr dazu
was ist mit der ärger groß also die
anweisungen des bmi an das bamf ist am
dienstag also gestern rausgegangen das
gespräch der kanzlerin da war ich wieder
anwesend noch kenne ich die inhalte dazu
kann ich keine stellung nehmen ich
glaube sie waren bei der pressekonferenz
der kanzlerin gestern die sich ja zu dem
gespräch dort geäußert hat es war ein
sehr nützliches gespräch und thema war
natürlich auch der zugang zu humanitärer
hilfe zu den zugang zu den bedürftigen
menschen in der region idleb der
hergestellt werden soll die kanzlerin
hat gesagt dass deutschland der 25 plus
100 millionen euro humanitäre hilfe zur
verfügung gestellt hat wie jetzt aber
natürlich wie die menschen dort
erreichen müssen über das dort gesagt
hinaus kann ich ihnen aus dem gespräch
nichts berichten
ich kann also ich habe einfach nur noch
mal gesagt was in jedem fall teil des
gespräches war
darüber hinaus kann ich ihnen aus dem
vertraulichen aus der vertraulichen
video-konferenz keine inhalte bekannt
geben
dazu also ich kann jetzt nur für uns
sprechen und will noch mal hervorheben
ist ist ja keine sozusagen ganz generell
losgelöste entscheidung sondern sie
hängt damit zusammen dass wir die
faktischen voraussetzungen im moment
nicht haben weil unsere partner nicht
mehr so verfügbar sind die wir brauchen
und weil auch die reisebeschränkungen
gelten
insofern ist das eine anpassung an die
reale situation die wir jetzt erleben
gut dann doch dazu noch fahren
ich weiß nicht ob man diese beiden dinge
unmittelbar unmittelbar miteinander
vergleichen kann es ist so dass wir die
resettlement verfahren nicht völlig
eigenständig durchführen können wir
brauchen die partner in den jeweiligen
staaten die bei dem prozess ganz
wichtige aufgaben wahrzunehmen haben und
die sind eben nicht mehr in der weise
verfügbar wie wir das benötigen das
betrifft die oem und auch uhren hcr und
das ist ein anderer sachverhalt als der
den die im vergleich angesprochen haben
dazu ist mir jetzt keine konkrete
entscheidung bekannt so wir haben noch
genau fünf minuten um halb müssen wir
enden
ich stelle jetzt auch eine frage von
außen die verschiedentlich gestellt wird
ob es zutrifft dass die bundesregierung
also wir sind jetzt sozusagen im
allgemeinen teil nochmal ob es zutrifft
dass die bundesregierung plant ein
hackathon also also ich gehört dass
übersetzt offenen programmierwettbewerb
veranstalten will ausgerufen vinnum mit
big data zusammenhang mit corona
umzugehen
das tut sie und zwar am 20
bis 22 märz wird eine reihe von sozialen
organisationen auf initiative von tech
for germany zusammen mit der
bundesregierung einen hexer organisieren
es geht letztlich darum als gesellschaft
die herausforderungen die im zuge der
panini der korona pandemie entstehen mit
neuen lösungen zu meistern und bis
freitagmorgen können alle bürgerinnen
und bürger sowie ministerien ihre
herausforderungen und probleme
einreichen für diese gerne lösung hätten
und dann wird während des hackers sonst
können sich dann gruppen einzelnen
problemen annehmen werden virtuell
zusammenarbeiten und hoffentlich
lösungen erarbeiten gerade in diesen
wochen ist es der bundesregierung ein
anliegen ein zeichen zu setzen dass die
digitalisierung natürlich in zeiten
dieser krise und in zeiten des social
distance sings was hier ja auch schon
vielfach beschrieben worden ist
ganz neue möglichkeiten auch zur
partizipation gibt helge braun hat
übrigens die schirmherrschaft über
diesen hektar
herr jessen
ich habe glaube ich eben schon mal
versucht ganz allgemein darauf
hinzuweisen dass es möglicherweise nicht
alles so läuft wie bisher und ich
entschuldige mich dafür dass ich das
nicht proaktiv angekündigt habe aber es
ja toll und ich bedanke mich bei den
kollegen der die frage noch gestellt hat
und wir würden wir hätten bestimmt noch
mittel und wege gefunden diesen hecke
von so publik zu machen dass bürger ihre
fragen stellen aber umso besser dass wir
das auch hier an können kosten so dann
gibt's haben noch möglichkeiten
vielleicht für zwei fragen gibt es noch
andere themen
also frau busse unter jungen waren die
ersten jungen fängt dann bitte
wir haben seit gestern dass die
einreisebeschränkungen die auf eu ebene
für drittstaatenangehörige die das
innenministerium jahr hier bekannt
gegeben hat und auch wieder in umsetzung
ist zuständig ist da sind ja dann schon
diese staaten auch getroffen wir haben
auch noch mal die länder und flughäfen
aufgefordert auch noch mal die lagen und
risiken neu zu bewerten was speziell
flüge aus risikoländern angeht aber das
prozedere das haben wir auch glaube ich
vielfach schon beschrieben ist so dass
für den gesundheitsschutz die
gesundheitsbehörden vor ort zuständig
sind und auch entsprechende
entscheidungen treffen ob nun welche
maßnahmen getroffen werden
dazu kann quarantäne gehören da kann
eben auch einreise und landeverbote dazu
gehören das liegt alleine schon der
zuständigkeit eben der
gesundheitsbehörden aber wie noch x mal
die haben noch mal gebeten eben aus
diese diese flüge aus risikoländern
dieses risiko noch mal zu bewerten
und hier die gesundheitsbehörden sind
dann auch noch mal aufgerufen
dies zu tun es gibt
einreisebeschränkungen vielleicht können
ja da auch gleich noch mal etwas zu
sagen die seit gestern in kraft sind
ich weiß nicht wann sie gleich ich kann
gern ich kann gerne ergänzen also wir
haben uns natürlich auch überlegt wie
wir jetzt vorgehen am besten war
sozusagen der aktuellen situation am
besten gerecht wird und wir haben uns
dazu entschieden zunächst mal mit
einreiseverboten zu agieren weil es
natürlich und das ist das prinzip der
der derzeitigen anordnung lage es gibt
eben personengruppen denen die einreise
nicht mehr gestattet werden kann und es
gibt personen gruppen die ein
berechtigtes interesse daran haben
einzureisen und das gilt im grunde
genommen weltweit von jedem land aus der
flugverbindung angeboten werden
und insofern ist es aus unserer sicht im
moment jedenfalls auch zutreffend und
richtig dass wir keine flugverbote
angeordnet haben im ersten schritt
sondern dass möglicherweise so lange die
flugverbindung von den anbietern noch
aufrechterhalten werden zumindest
diejenigen beispielsweise deutsche
staatsangehörige die vielleicht diese
bildung nutzen wollen dann auch die
möglichkeit haben nach hause zu kommen
es ist damit zu rechnen dass der
flugverkehr sich also das
passagieraufkommen sich weiter reduziert
das sehen wir auch in an den landgrenzen
zur schweiz frankreich österreich und
luxemburg und inwieweit die
fluggesellschaften den flugbetrieb dann
aufrechterhalten das muss man sehen dass
das vielleicht noch in einem wichtigen
punkt ergänzen den er jetzt ja auch
nicht nur personenverkehr sondern auch
einige güter verkehr
für uns ist ganz wichtig dass luftfracht
weiter möglich ist wir wollen
infrastruktur aufrechterhalten und auch
flughäfen offen halten um die versorgung
zu sichern um die logistik zu sichern
sie wissen dass eben ganz viel eben per
luftfracht auch zu uns ins land kommt
ganz wichtige versorgungsgüter und das
ist eben enorm bedeutsam dass wir diese
verkehre auch aufrecht erhalten eine
letzte ergänzung das vielleicht auch
nicht ganz trivial und unwichtig das
verkehrsministerium hat ja die
luftfahrtgesellschaften auch über diesen
umstand informiert und das führt
natürlich in der folge auch dazu dass
zumindest versucht wird das bereits beim
einsteigen in die flugzeuge am
ausgangspunkt personen die
offensichtlich also die offensichtlich
keine chance auf einreise haben dass die
gar nicht erst zu steigen so dass es
nicht zu diesen sehr umständlichen
zurückweisung vorgehen kommt letzte
frage hamburg
nee das ist jetzt heute erstmal das
kabinett gegangen also das kabinett hat
einfach heute entschieden einen
kabinettsausschuss zur bekämpfung von
rechtsextremismus einzurichten um die
umsetzung des am 30
oktober 2009 10 im bundeskabinett
beschlossenen maßnahmenpakets gegen
rechtsextremismus und hasskriminalität
zu begleiten
und außerdem soll dieser kabinett
ausschuss dann weitere auch präventive
maßnahmen zur effektiven bekämpfung
insbesondere rechtsextremismus rassismus
antisemitismus und weiteren phänomenen
der gruppenbezogenen
menschenfeindlichkeit in deutschland
vorbereitet werden
er hat jetzt ja heute damit noch nicht
getagt wir haben vielleicht ergänzen
frau denn es ist so dass der
bundesinnenminister als beauftragter als
vorsitzender dieses ausschusses benannt
wurde und nach meiner kenntnis weitere
ständige mitglieder sind der
bundesminister des auswärtigen die
bundesministerin der justiz und für
verbraucherschutz die bundesministerin
der verteidigung die bundesministerin
für familie senioren frauen und jugend
die bundesministerin für bildung und
forschung und der bundesminister für
besondere aufgaben sowie
staatsministerin widmann mauz
staatsministerin cruz und staatssekretär
seibert aber themenbezogen können andere
mitgliedern einbezogen werden wenn ihre
zuständigkeit betroffen ist gut damit
sind wir am ende dieser
regierungspressekonferenz danke nochmal
für das verständnis für alle
häufigkeiten dann gefahren für ihn
besuch alles gute